the Joe Rogan experience divisions never
been more exciting you know there's
still a dangerous dangerous fighter in
the world champ that is hilarious
what made you say just like look I need
something I need something tomorrow's
actually I wasn't even it's funny but
it's somebody high-profile that dared me
to my didn't I can't do it I'm challenge
me so much he's like I dare you knows
like ah alright sounded of doing the
video and they knows I got do what am i
doing oh that's hilarious but look who
would it's done shows like we Sayed I
say I saved an entire division because
anyway I wanted to cut its neck off and
he told me that do something about what
you did that's like this is what Connor
did this is what Chael Sonnen was
probably the best at it the original
shell son is the original pro wrestling
style [ __ ] talker in MMA that really
made people hyped up about fights I mean
she got to give credit to jail because
before jail there was you know I'm gonna
[ __ ] him up I'm gonna kick his ass
people always talk [ __ ] but they never
talk [ __ ] with with an entertainers
flair wait jail did I mean even though
you kind of knew that jail was in over
his head in some of those fights like
with John Jones
I had a real deep feeling he was in over
his head with Anderson Silva in the
second fight in particular you know I
just had a feeling he was in over his
head but he would still talk so much it
was so fun and it made the fights way
bigger they should all thank him thank
you for what you said about my mother
thank you thank you thank you for all
that crazy [ __ ] you said because that
that's what really sold that fight
they all made more money because of him
yeah man and the thing is is what I
admire about that now like a guy like
Kobe obviously Connor
even Ronda I think Rondo was more of a
persona it was more the fact that the
pressure that comes with that she like
dude that's like a whole nother fight
and you got to make sure that you got a
little Tirek expectations would you
think of the pillows the laughs like
dude I really got to be dominating guys
heads but dude it was funny it was funny
it's extra pressure on you right down
you lose people are so happy but check
this out this is how crazy I am that
pressure man I chant like channel that
thing and I almost love it joy it's
crazy I got like felts and the pillows
with TJ's head and DJ's had hilarious
the king of cream bend the knee so what
what did your friend that you won't say
the person's name week you say with
their name rhymes with tell me later but
what did what did they save you I could
watch it you have to come up with this
character is that what they said you
know I think it was after I beat
Demetrius Johnson I went to the to the
apex fight with I happened to be there
and randomly and then obviously Dana was
there at the fight and I pulled him
aside said hey dinner lets you know how
are you well none that he would actually
want to talk to me because I hate come
to my office so I ended up you know
going from the fights to his office he's
and we're you know I was in his Fred
Ferrari freaking really nice to us and
he said hey but I just want to let you
know that uh you know that I'm thinking
I'm thinking I'm thinking about getting
rid of the division or I'm gonna get rid
of the division this is what ronnapee
Demetrius Johnson Matt you know what I'm
saying like there's there's new blood
and he told me straight up and I'm just
like man I have to do something man like
if I don't if I won't start speaking up
if I don't start being hated like my
divisions gonna drown - and it's up to
me and I felt like that something that
Demetrius never did so I tell you why it
wasn't entertaining it was oh people
don't uh
people don't pay attention I think
because the Mitchells are so dominant
like they don't appreciate true art man
dimitra's was so dominant that he heard
a division because there's like it gets
born there has to be a storyline a
storyline to people and Demetrius wasn't
the most personable dude in the world so
then I took that upon myself when he
said that I wanted to come with a
gimmick you know I wasn't originally
originally I was supposed to go 235
pounds right and and I brought TJ doxa
father go to 235 pounds or they were
gonna strip me from my belt like this is
a contract and that was the original
plans for me to go up but then I decided
to come down and keep the division and
kind of fight for it
[Applause]